and homophobia in the met I also said to
her that she was very clear in her
report about her views about you the
commissioner and your deputy and the
confidence that she had in you
but I said was she disappointed I asked
her was she disappointed that you hadn't
been able to accept the findings of
institutionalized racism sexism misogyny
and homophobia and I just wanted to read
to you what she said to me in response
she said I think the Met commissioner is
unfortunately splitting hairs over words
she then went on to say I feel it is a
really missed opportunity
deep into this I just felt it is a shame
I hope that over the next few weeks and
months as the commissioner gets more
into meeting londoners and listening to
what they have to say he will not only
accept my diagnosis but accept what is
not a label but an accurate description
of the organization
I think he is letting his police down I
think he's letting his stuff down and I
just wondered if you just want to
comment on what baroness Casey said and
whether you've changed your mind after
the week the few weeks that have gone
since the publication of the the review
I I keep reflecting I keep thinking
about this because I know
um it's a word that matters deeply
um uh to some people in some quarters
but I'm still at the moment of the same
view I've completely accepted the
diagnosis that
Louise lays out in her in her report the
fact that we have racism misogyny and
homophobia in the organization the fact
that it's not simply a few individuals
that are systemic and cultural failings
in there and the fact that it affects
the experience of our people in the
organization and affects the experience
of of the public in terms of policing so
I I fully I fully accept those issues
and I was speaking out in very much the
same terms from the moment I was
appointed last September well before her
report because I've been very clear that
I came back to policing after
nearly five years out because it's a
moment for reform and policing and I
want to be part of that because I care
deeply about the public
the reason
I know I've in many ways I might have
made life harder for myself but the
reason I'm not accepting it is
it means so many different things to
different people
um
she sets out very closely what the test
is the four the four tests and her and
I'm agreeing with her tests but her her
definition if you like is different from
first and definition it's different to
some dictionary definitions I've been
asked at least three different
definitions in media interviews over the
last last few weeks some of them mean
nobody's a racist and it's just about
system all the way through to some of
them mean
um mostly organization of racist or
misogynist and that's the sort of that's
the conundrum for me is I'm not going to
put a label around my organization which
has so many different interpretations
because every time I use it I can't say
I'm using that word and by that I mean
this this this and not that that and
that so if that's the reason I'm doing
it you stand by I mean because that
became the story didn't it at the time
of the publication the story was you not
accepting the the definition of
institutionalized Casey we discussed it
well before publishing reports you knew
my view she knew those those issues and
she decided to make it the story I just
wondered just on this issue the the
national head of the police Federation I
think Steve Hart's home had said that he
did accept the the definition within the
Met of being institutional racist sexist
and homophobic he said it it was
necessary and I think he did this in a
personal capacity but he said it was
necessary to provide the leadership to
recognize that what would you say about
that
Steve's entitled to his own opinion
there are there aren't different
opinions there are people at different
levels in the Met who agree with me and
some who some who don't and that's this
is a really
tricky issue I'm simply saying I'm not
as the commissioner going to put a label
to my organization that gets interpreted
by many as meaning the majority of
people are misogynist or racist or
whatever and that's but none of this
should the focus should be what we're
going to do about it because sort of 25
years since MacPherson 30 years since
um
of Stephen Lawrence
lots of good people
have tried hard to improve things home
secretaries police authorities police
and crime Commissioners Mayors
Commissioners leaders across policing
and as you said yourself at the start
progress has been made but clearly
we have not collectively dug deep enough
to make the difference need to be made
and that's why this reform is required
um I just want to ask you another couple
of questions before I move on to other
colleagues
um this morning that the Home Secretary
I believe is making a speech about a
return to Common Sense policing at a
Back to Basics Think Tank uh I think
she's a super claiming that the police
policing is too woke
time we're obviously discussing the
rather shocking the shocking findings of
baroness cases report and as we've just
been talking about the institutionalized
racism sexism homophobia in the largest
police force in the country I
explain to the committee how you manage
to balance a common sense culture in
policing where effective and robust
operational policing is possible
whilst also tackling those deep-seated
institutional racism sexism and
homophobic problems under the prejudices
that exist that we've seen that can
undermine clearly undermines effective
Frontline policing how do you do that
I'm not I'm not sure I accept his
attention
um attention between the two offices are
inherently
um practical in what they do it's a it's
a very practical profession and
day in and day out we've got officers
going out across London
um looking to make a difference being
um being practical being determined
um being courageous and supporting
victims
I think one of the challenges that I see
as part of our reform program in the
mayor is
an over complexity of policy that
sometimes slows officers down a lack of
equipment that Louise Casey calls out
something we're already looking at is
the
um the way our Frontline officers don't
feel set up to succeed they don't feel
they've got the equipment the resources
there are many examples in her report to
that to that effect so I think there are
lots of practical things we need to do
to help officers succeed some of that's
buried in policy
um but I don't see
attention about
I don't know Common Sense neat success I
don't see a problem in at all right
would you ever allow concerns about
being branded racist to prevent the
sanctioning of police investigations
into issues such as grooming gangs
so so without fear so our Cornerstone is
without without fear or favor and that
doesn't mean we've always got that right
but that's absolutely what we stand for
and we should be prepared to go after
anybody regardless of sort of their
position regardless of a position of
power regardless of race Faith
Creed anything at all which shouldn't
make any difference at all and I think
the vast majority of time in policing it
hasn't done occasionally but maybe
examples where we've
slips up in that regard but it shouldn't
be a factor okay thank you very much
James Daly thank you very much so Mark I
am staggered by what you've just said
genuinely
um that I'll tell you a label for
Metropolitan Police and certainly it's
management and this is the nice version
is incompetent and that's the nice
version of it the idea that you've had a
string of good people coming in who've
been working hard well every single one
of them has failed because the situation
that you find yourself in in this
organization is a National Disgrace and
without being open and saying that we
are at a at a stage where this
organization is just not functioning and
one example of that is can you tell me
how many people police officers accused
of domestic or sexual violence are
currently serving on on the front line
in the metropolitan police
there's two different there's two
different parts there
um I need to challenge you on the first
point you've made the first point is
suggesting that
um the whole organization everybody in
it is rotten I think what we need to be
told competent so so well that's just
not accurate is it and what we have to
do now we need a serious conversation
about police reform I mean serious
conversation about police reform if that
becomes pillory of the good majority of
people that won't help anybody there are
big challenges leadership
um there are leadership failings
definitely there are hundreds of people
in the organization who shouldn't be
there there are all those problems I
completely accept but if if our debate
about police reform police priorities
becomes one of pillaring everybody well
that doesn't serve the public yeah well
that's just you know we we it's time
that politicians called out organization
management the management of
organizations like yours for what it is
a complete not a mess it's been a
completeness for a long time and see
senior police officers must have turned
the Blind Eye to what was going on
because the same issues that we are
dealing with here today we could have
been asking you questions 10 years ago
so can I ask you how many police
officers who have been convicted or
under investigation for sexual or
domestic violence offending or serving
in front of the front line capacity
today
I'm not going to pluck an exact number
out there we're we're doubling with the
biggest doubling down on standards in
policing for 50 years we have
um we've more than doubled the numbers
being sacked
um we are um we have far more officers
suspended we've got far more cases going
to gross misconduct hearings we're
looking at a different way of doing
vetting procedures to help us remove
people from the organization who aren't
aren't fit for purpose and I've been
asking the Home Secretary and they're
doing a review for powers that make it
easier with misconduct we're doing an
awful lot about this we have done
reviews looking back and we've got data
which has been put in the public domain
about the number of officers where we
have had allegations of sexual offending
or domestic abuse and I was just asking
you you're the commissioner today how
many officers have been committed
convicted you can have those matters are
serving in Frontline positions you can
pick 100 questions with different
numbers that I'm not going to answer
here today I can come back on detailed
numbers afterwards but I thought you
would know that somehow because in that
the basic thing that you would be
concerned that officers who are guilty
of sexual offending you are sending them
out to deal with the most vulnerable
situations and that doesn't seem to
bother anybody in the audience I'm not
saying that's not true at all so tell me
the number and tell me what you're doing
about it I'm not going to plug a number
out there we've been really clear we've
done operation Onyx which is a review of
all those who've had allegations those
allegations have been previously
investigated and
um found to have no case to answer we're
concerned about history because mistakes
have been made there's about
1130 cases in that
a little shy of 250 of them we found no
problem and a little shy of 200 of them
we've got concerns about and are going
into a vetting review process and the
other 600 or so are there are mislines
of inquiry or new lines of inquiry that
we followed through on so we are
doubling down on these standards issues
but I'm I'm not going to accept pillary
of the majority of people in the
organization that's not he's making an
excuse I'm asking I'm asking a specific
questions about the problems that are
leading to people being treated in the
most appalling Manner and just simply
coming here and saying I'm not going to
answer this because it it tells
everybody that's not the point there's
lots of good police officers in
Metropolitan in place those good police
officers have been let down by your
predecessors and Senior Management of
the of the police you were before you
came back you stood in the senior
position in the metropolitan police you
must have seen that that was about 2018.
you must have seen these problems at
that stage I can't find any statements
from usmo back in 2018 when you were a
Deputy Commissioner saying it's
outrageous that we've got police
officers that are uh that shouldn't be
serving in the organization and you seem
to be typical of of a senior police
officer at the Metropolitan Police who's
just gone along with this gone along
with this negligence this incompetence
turned a blind eye and that's why we're
here today and I have real concerns
about that
we have made much progress over the last
few decades as the chair said at the
start but it is not enough and we are
doubling down on standards more
ferocious than has been done for five
decades we're removing people faster and
we're tackling these issues but the vast
majority of our people are good people
and a debate which turns this into
um pillory of the police route and
branch is is not something I'm going to
accept because we have men and women
going out there today determined to
protect londoners being brave being
compassionate and they need
they need your support as much as they
need my support whilst we tackle the
fundamental systemic issues which have
let them down and let the public down if
somebody is find us through questions
um if somebody's a metropolitan police
officer is convicted of a criminal
offense or is found there is sufficient
evidence to find that sexual
um or sexual violence or sexually
inappropriate behavior has been
undertaken by the officer I do you
is there a process and do you agree that
you should sack them on the spot
um I'd love to have the power to do so
you do have the power to do that that's
not true so
most police misconduct is dealt with by
independent lawyers I do not have the
last say who is a police officer so we
have people who have been sacked by
senior police officers and then
reinstated by independent legally
qualified chairs at the either in the
all police appeals tribunals who put
them back in the organization there is a
complex system where I don't have the
final say who's in the organization
that's one of the changes I've asked for
we also have police regulations which
have no explicit power to remove an
officer who fails vetting
Commissioners have been lobbying for
this for over 20 years and politicians
haven't been prepared to move the rules
well again I don't accept that for a
second you're the only organization in
the country it's true you're the only
organization there for some Mark in the
country who can quite happily and we're
not happily can quite
um Can tolerate people who've indulged
in Behavior the most serious not
tolerating at all well they're still
serving in your organization
so but you're you are telling us
today that those people whose Behavior
matches that that you whatever the
process that comes after it that you and
your organization will sack them
immediately if they're convicted of a
criminal offense or they are found
guilty of sexual or sexually
inappropriate behavior or domestic
violence of course that's that's they
will immediately be sacked by you
um that's illegal I'm not allowed to if
it's exactly myself that's misconduct
yes but misconduct processes aren't in
the hands of police Chiefs but they are
in the hands of independent legally
qualified chairs that's one of the
changes the rules I'm asking for so I
will do everything I can to remove the
organization but it's not always my
decision and we've got many cases where
they've been reinstated out with of our
power so but my intention is absolutely
to do that right and have you had any
indication from the Home Secretary when
she's likely to make any announcement
about changes to misconduct I'm
expecting in the next few weeks it's
it's within a few weeks within a few
weeks thank you Simon fell thank you
chair and thank you so much for joining
us
um
operation Onyx you you rattled through
some figures
um when talking to my my colleague a few
uh minutes ago could you uh just update
us where you are on this in terms of the
review which I think was due to close at
the end of last month
um where you are in terms of officers
facing dismissal and those facing
criminal investigation as well so
um just to recap
if you look at cases like cousins and
Carrick you see that there are missed
opportunities to deal with sort of some
of the most awful individuals
because of that I ordered a review of 10
years of data so 10 years of cases where
allegations have been made against
officers that are either
of sexual misconduct of sexual
criminality or domestic abuse
every one of those individuals so that
identified Eleven Hundred and I can find
the numbers in a minute if you want 1100
and something individuals it's in the
public domain in a less letter or a term
Secretary in there just over 1100
individuals
um we didn't just look at those cases we
looked at those individuals in the
rounds so
um Beyond those cases and this was a
first stage of sort of triage and review
process I think there were 13 data sets
and an awful lot of analysis and
research and reviewing evidence done as
I say sort of around 250 were found to
have no problems
um
there was a another sort of 600 odd
where
either the investigators felt they were
missed investigative opportunities on
the original cases so need to have a
fresh look at that or because of taking
a wider look at that individual through
a new investigative lines of inquiry so
there were over 600 where we want to
look further
um and that work is now happening and
then there were
just shy of 200 where there were
um some residual concerns and we were
putting them into a sort of a vetting
review process so we went through that
that process now those next stages of
work are are taking place
I know these numbers are deeply
concerning one of the things we're doing
differently is we're bringing outside
experts in so we've got
um sort of experts from different
um
sexually abused sort of Charities and um
and domestic abuse Charities and victim
support organizations Etc and so they're
looking over our shoulders so all these
decisions so we're re-looking at this
with a fresh pair of eyes and a more
assertive approach and also asking
others to sort of make sure that we're
marking the homework sort of
appropriately so to speak so I'm I'm
sure that we'll be moving many will be
reinstate doing fresh investigations or
removing officers for vetting failures
in many of these cases and that's what
we're working through at the moment
thank you and and you're right those are
large numbers and they will be of
concern do you have a time frame for for
the
um 600 individuals you're taking fresh
like that and the 200-ish you have
genuine concerns about how long that
process is going to take it's going to
take several months to work through all
those cases and all those investigations
and because we've because we've shaken
the tree so vigorously we've got more
reports coming in a misconduct we've got
more officers standing up and saying I'm
worried about X or Y
um so we've got more of that coming in
so we've got two things that I'm dealing
one is this what I might call Legacy
cases where we're looking back and
saying actually we know we've made
mistakes in history when our misconduct
process haven't been strong enough we've
looked back at Key issues
and we will find problems that were
missed and we've got to deal with those
individuals
secondly we're shaking the tree we're
getting more allegations from officers
more allegations from the public which
is positive and that's generating the
bigger caseload going forward and so
balancing those two case loads is
challenging we put sort of over 200 new
offices into that environment and on
short-term measures recently as I've
said publicly we've been
um uh tasking officers to support them
from
counterterrorism and specialist crime
commands and that's been helping greatly
and what I've been encouraged by is the
number of officers volunteering to help
out because the vast majority get this
is is so critical for for us and they
want to make a difference
thank you and and while this
investigation is going on what's the
status of those individuals who are
being looked at do they still have one
cards they still
um so the majority of them do because
they've been investigated in the past
fans have no case to answer and now
we're picking over those cases again as
soon as we find something of deep
concern their status of review they
might be restricted or suspended are
they restricted in what they're doing at
the moment so so if there's not
something around some sort of sexual
assault or something like that they they
can still work on cases like that so
these are I divide this into two things
so a
a fresh allegation of domestic abuse
that he's been investigated criminally
he's likely to lead to restriction or
probably a suspension
cases which have been historically dealt
with and closed
and no um no fault being found in that
initial investigation
we're re-looking at those if any of
those get to a stage where we decide
actually we're seriously concerned about
this officer then clearly restriction or
suspension is likely again
just
think of why these cases aren't all
straightforward and why
um some aren't concerning So within
these cases you will have for example
um
so on suffering Mental Health crisis has
been in police custody who alleges
everyone in custody rate her and
um has been sectioned shortly afterwards
and the whole of the custody block is
videoed and sort of so the the the
evidence that there's no concern here
it's just a sad sad case it's very
powerful so you get a range from the
sort of sad and malicious to the deeply
worrying and sifting through that is not
always straightforward but that's what
we're doing
I appreciate that but one of the issues
that baroness Casey raised was
obviously public perception and the
concern there but also you know in her
in her words whether the Met is able to
police itself
um so for those sort of 250 which would
fall into that bracket you've just
described
yeah what sort of external check is that
there to to reassure the public that
actually you're dismissal of them is
robust and that the public does can have
confidence in these officers that's why
we've got this independent Advisory
Group and they're looking through all
these cases and so say double checking
our thinking and so uh I'll be that'll
provide us with confidence that provide
us with that sort of third eye which is
really helpful saying well I think this
is what it looks like but maybe that's
sort of a blinker View and you've got
somebody else providing that but also it
provides it for the public in terms of
independent experts have looked at these
cases and said yeah we agree with the
police decision on that so that's what
they're those independent experts are
working through those cases at the
moment
thank you and then last question for me
uh
um one of baroness Casey's other
um findings which is very powerful when
she was in front of us was
essentially reform or die so if you
don't get this right and if you don't
land this right then the Met should not
exist in in its current form be very
keen to hear your thoughts on on that
and what an answer to that might look
like if if we can't land this process
properly and if you can't regain the
public The public's conference
we will succeed in reform
this is not an overnight issue if you
look at
this is this is several years work but
you will see progress quarter by quarter
that that's what I absolutely promise if
you look at
big organizations in any sector that get
into a situation where they're heading
in the wrong direction
there is never a sort of Silver Bullet
solution to it
you have to come up with the right
the right plan which the big
organization there's going to be
multiple parts to that and we can talk
about our turnaround plan that we
published and the work we're doing to
reform you have to go with the right
plan and then it just comes down to
Relentless delivery
step-by-step improving there is and sort
of any big organizations that
reach for some creative
um Silver Bullet solution it never works
I think we'll have some questions about
how we will be able to monitor that of
course yes and can I just ask you a lot
of things one is have you got any
serving police officers at the moment
who have criminal convictions yes
and what are you doing about that I
think the public would be shocked to
know that a serving police officer has a
criminal conviction all right so
I think if we can make it not completely
binary I think there'll be a small
number of cases which people would none
of us would be worried about so someone
who at 14 gets a caution for something
very very minor and at 28 having had a
work history Etc joins the place I don't
think people would be
concerned about some of those cases but
serious crime or and or crime committed
as a police officer that that has no
place in policing absolutely agree with
you completely
um we have
um too many cases where
um where that is true how many police
officers do you have who've had
um those numbers are in the letter that
we put publicly to the mayor and the
Home Secretary and I I can't pull out
the back of my head I can't remember it
but we that thumbs in public domain so
we have too many of them and
um they have they suspended from Duty or
are they what are they what's happened
to them
um so this is where this is why I want
legal change to the current regulation
so what's happened to them today what
are they doing today so if I thought
through the process so they get
investigated so they they've gone to
they've gone to court they've got a
criminal conviction
um they then go to a misconduct panel
um which
no I understand all that I'm just
wondering today and then were they
serving officers with a warrant card
doing so so then they're reinstated
often against often against uh our will
we then got a police officer who we
don't think should be a police officer
we've got some concerns about so we put
restrictions on them so we have to have
them in the workplace because that's the
decision so depending what the
convictions for we might have
restrictions on them so we have officers
we have offices in the organization who
are restricted
um from for example getting involved in
evidence or officers restricted from
having public contact it's completely
ridiculous okay
admire in the Home Secretary that's
available to the public I was probably
publicized that two or three weeks ago
so
yeah and that's
that's the one yeah okay
so then I've got one more question that
I'm going to go to Lee Anderson very
quickly if you are a dinner lady you're
a school government when I work with a
certain vulnerable people you have to
have a DPS check on a regular basis
you are a police officer and you fail a
DPS check how can it be justified that
you remain in post
um I agree with you so
we have a we're under different
employment law to most people so
something called police regulations as
opposed to normal employment law and
police regulations prescribe all the
processes for
um for for misconduct for unsatio
performance and they are
um
complex and
Byzantine and I don't think they're
right at all and that's why I've been
asking for reform of them and that so
that creates these these issues where
very simple issues under normal
employment law you'd be saying goodbye
to somebody
um become quite complex issues in
policing and often don't produce that
result and it's not acceptable I say and
sort of
um Commissioners have been asking for
change in this for over 20 years but
um
those lobbying to keep these sort of
rules have won so that's why I'm asking
for it I'm just looking at
looking at say that 161 police officers
in the Met have a criminal conviction
yeah and I think it's also says that the
majority 70 of the 161 had a conviction
uh before they became an officer but it
then goes on to say that um eight
officers committed their offense whilst
in the met and remained serving and a
further 49 officers have convictions for
crimes of dishonesty or violence
oh is that impossible it's unacceptable
isn't it I think that's quite shocking
actually I agree I'm agreeing with you
right okay I'm not I'm not defending the
vast there's a small number of people
who you would say if it's in that minor
historic young people box but the
majority of it is completely
unacceptable yeah and I think actually
we we heard about the case of
case the conviction and as I understand
it is still serving in the metropolitan
police today yeah those there's many
cases not the many the tens of cases
that are completely unacceptable it's
disgraceful
excuse me I just wanted to ask you the
uplift data figures have been published
um one force the Metropolitan Police
Service did not meet its total uplift
allocation the force missed its
allocation of
4557 additional officers by 1089 that's
23.9 percent
what do you say about that that was
obviously a government priority wasn't
it to get the the uplift figure up to
20. so we are a thousand officers light
of our Target
um I wish we'd hit it but we we haven't
why haven't you um so I think there are
a range of there are a range of factors
in this and we've we have recruited over
the last three years more than nine
thousand officers
which is
um the most I think ever in such a short
period
um we haven't hit the we haven't hit the
target obviously we are striving to
maintain the quality that's really
important I think there are factors
which include both I think the
reputation the organization at the
moment doesn't help recruiting
um but also
um the employment Market in the pay
situation is really challenging so the
employment Market in London as you all
know is very very hot and very difficult
and officer paper into Frontline officer
paypoints have gone down 17 in real
terms in a decade so we're
paying people
um less and new recruits Less in a the
hottesting part of the employment Market
in the country so I think that's a
factor as well and I hope that
um prb in this year's settlement goes
some way towards addressing that okay
all right well thank you for answering
that Lee Anderson thanks chair
um thanks commissioner for coming and
keep taking these questions
um I'd like to tell the committee please
um give examples of cases of racism
misogynism and sexism which you
personally witnessed while serving as a
police officer and what did you do about
it
I I have
I have always been tough on standards in
the organization
give me examples of sexism racism and
misogynistic behavior that you've
actually witnessed whilst being a police
officer I can't remember any immediately
I can't remember any no I can't well I
find that very difficult to believe
I think everybody watching this would
find that difficult to believe that
you're in charge of cleaning up the the
map Force really it's your it's your
responsibility but you can't actually
remember any
you did you seriously expect I committed
to believe that so I as a senior officer
I I've sat on many misconduct panels
I've pretty much dismissed everybody
who's come in front of me on those
panels I've always been very tough on
them as to what you'd actually witnessed
yourself I find it pretty hard to
believe that a police officer with you
know years and years of service with an
organization has not witnessed any of
this when we know it goes off because if
you have you must be walking around with
your eyes closed so
there are many offices in the
organization so when you look at the um
say the case report and all these issues
there are offices in the organization
who are
angry and upset because they recognize
this and they've had these experiences
they're officers who haven't seen it and
don't recognize it people have different
experiences in the organization you've
actually witnessed it racism sectors
I've seen nothing like that in the map
no but I've only worked in the Met for
six years as a very senior officer it
doesn't come across your desk in that
way in the time you've been in the
police
I'm not going to try and test my memory
to go back to the 1980s
right okay I think that's what your
answer is my question I think yeah it
would appear that you're in denial that
um at all I've been more forthright
about the need to reform and the meeting
confront standards in policing than any
commissioner for decades I would imagine
that anybody else in any any other
industry has witnessed this type of
behavior and would admit to it and say
yes it does it does exist it has
happened I have witnessed it I think
you're probably the only person I've
ever met that would say they can't
remember
I'm not going to get into a case-by-case
discussion I'm it's one case then just
one case no I'm going to close by case
Susan I'm I'm absolutely determined to
tackle issues in the organization I've
always been tough on standards and I'll
continue to be we are going to reform
the issues that need tackling
I need the support of politicians in
dealing with this I need the regulations
to change and I need the help to to
build on the politicians commission
you've got to be honest and to sit there
and say I've been more remember that
when you've witnessed these incidents I
don't think that's very honest at all
people don't misbehave in front of
senior officers in that way that's
that's an unrealistic questioning
officer
of course I haven't I said it's one
policing in 1987. did you witness any
the behavior in the 80s and 90s was very
different to today of course it was I
said did you witness it of course I've
seen things that sort of weren't weren't
fit for today's standards but I'm going
to get into detail about that today
we're about reforming policing and we
need the support of politicians to do
that to help us with the right
regulations we've already doubled down
on standards as I said we're sacking
officers at twice the rate we're having
the biggest look of Professional
Standards that's been done in 50 years
and
that is a sign of our absolute
commitment we started that from day one
of my time as commissioner and
um I'm you know grateful the Home
Secretary is looking to help us by
changing the regulations yeah well I
think you want to regular after that
one's commissioner I'll um I'll try
another question we've seen protesters
again once again in Parliament Square
setting up some sort of Glastonbury on
tens on terms gazebo with uh some pretty
poor artists if if
memory says it right
um do you agree with the the
recommendations I think it was by the
the politic change that there should be
zero tolerance to these sort of events
um and we shouldn't be putting up we're
going to social behavior and just this
morning we've seen protesters on my tour
around Parliament Square probably as you
was coming into the building do you
think it's time that you left the Ivory
Tower and got out there on White on
sorted these people out because you know
people of London the tourists the people
that work at this place and you know the
taxi drivers the bus drivers the game
Fed Up of it and you're just letting it
happen you've got the powers now to do
this
so
um there's current bill bouncing around
Parliament which hasn't come in yet so
those pairs aren't in existence yet
um so it's not particularly true is it
you can move these people on they've
shopped in the highway so
we could have a long conversation about
probably called the law moving them on
well because you're I don't want a long
conversation you're making you're making
selective
um comments based on a partial
understanding of the law I do not want
londoners disrupted
um any more than anybody else does but
the law is very clear that protest is
disruptive and to a reason and to a
certain extent that is allowed that is
what the law says at the moment now you
might not like that but I have to work
to the law rather than
um not right rather than win now it is
it is right
so so it's you might want to believe
that the law says that no disruption has
allowed whatsoever through protest but
that is not the case I think you might
want to believe commissioner that you
know that you're doing your job
correctly I don't think you are but I'll
just want to ask one more question I'll
make one more statement because I feel
like I'm wasting my time with it to be
honest
um you see you took five years out of
the force there's probably people listen
to this today wish it was a lot longer
and I'm one of them
um do you think you've got the
confidence of the public I'm not going
to sit here when if it wants to be
personally offensive then write it in
newspapers but I'm not going to answer
those questions
okay I don't I don't think we want to be
personally offensive I think we're
trying to get to what the problems are
in the met and how you're going to
tackle them can I just ask a question
about the the issue of the protests
it is because of what's happening out in
in Parliament square is that the reason
why we saw this week I think it was the
Prime Minister being driven down uh
Whitehall with a sort of a whole number
of police officers on bicycles and then
a whole number of police officers
running alongside the the Entourage is
that is that now how well policing has
to protect the Prime Minister because of
the protests out in Parliament Square
so there was a large planned protest in
Parliament Square
um the parliament the Prime Minister was
returning to um his office for some
urgent business and so
um we dealt with those two conflicting
pressures to get the part and prime
minister back into his office I've never
seen so many police officers on bicycles
and running at great speed
with a car I mean it's for rather
reminiscent of the American president
and the way they operate anyway we'll
move on to Carolyn Harris you won't
often see a protected person being taken
through a large protest but on that
occasion it was necessary so that's why
you saw some unusual tactics so that was
a one-off we're not going to see see
that that's not the routine no okay
those officers looked a bit out of poof
actually they were running down the
fitness test
okay right Carolyn Harris uh thank you
chair
um
Mark baroness Casey um pointed to the
Parliamentary and diplomatic Service as
being particularly bad If we're honest
yes
um why is that ready
so
I think there's a range of reasons in
there by the way she also appointed
frankly she pointed out that there's
there are cultural challenges across our
Firearms commands it wasn't just about
parliamentary impact of protection so I
think parliamentary diplomatic
protection there's a range of things we
need to do
um we said we changed the leadership we
are a third of the sergeants have
changed recently it's an unusual role I
mean you see that sort of around here
sort of static protection it doesn't
appeal hasn't appealed historically to
that many officers so I think we've had
a very static Workforce who hasn't
helped
um the working Arrangements have been
designed over the years in a way which
has
um reduce the ability of Supervisors to
supervise because the way people are on
post and the way it's been funded and
organized and some of the facilities
they operate in hasn't helped so there's
been a range of factors which have
created a unit which looks and works
very different to other policing units
and
um some bad cultures have got a hold
there and that's not acceptable I think
I think it's being termed by some police
officers operate as as an overtime
operation and then it's attracted to
police officers who may want to carry
again is there is there no
um accountability then on those who may
have been in charge of that
particular unit is it the management and
the senior Personnel in bringing order
into that unit one of the challenges for
um the overtime issue for example
um these aren't all for lack of lack of
trying so
we struggle to recruit as many Firearms
offices in London as we need um so
across the different commands and that
means that in in not just that operation
but other operations we have officers
doing a lot of overtime to cover posts
that we couldn't recruit people into so
um some of those things don't come out
of mismanagement that come out of
management trying to stretch a limited
amount of resources to cover more posts
than are ideal so some of those issues
are
um are part of it of course if we find
individuals who knew about bad behavior
and Tackle didn't tackle it of course
we'll tackle them as well
did you not have responsibility for this
unit at one point oh um when I was
responsible for the national all the
folks to counterterrorism
um the protection commands were part of
my responsibilities so I had sort of
um the national lead for fighting cancer
terrorism
um sort of 10 000 people across the
country in different roles including the
protection commands yes
but given that that unit has access to
um some of the most important people in
the country and some of the most
important visitors to the country is
native more important than they are
highly scrutinized and that you are we
or you and we can have confidence that
we're not exposing people to people who
may be
not behave in an acceptable manner
I completely agree with that I think
sort of so what all of these reviews
show is that the
um the vetting standards the way we've
done Professional Standards
investigations those issues that we are
tackling now those systems that we've
all relied on haven't been as strong as
they need to be and that's caused these
problems completely agree with you yeah
so operation 11 is going to be doing a
Littleton Branch investigation into this
it seems really strange to me that one
of them what should be one of the most
respected services in the United Kingdom
at this state and Stage needs to be
having a rotten Branch investigation
into how the team its officers are
working no we should be respecting the
police not expecting them to investigate
themselves
how is the operation coming along
so um that operation is all about say
starting the changes in parliamentary
professional protection so so the senior
leadership team has all changed the
third of the sizes have changed
um we have uh we're doing a different
recruiting approaches to get younger
officers different mix of offices more
diverse mixed officers in and you'll
start to see those changes coming
through around you in Parliament so it's
making progress but I think across our
Firearms commands as Louise Casey points
out there's some more fundamental
reforms that that are required
um we're looking to get a sort of senior
officer in with who's not spent time in
the Met to sort of help lead that work
and um and that will develop over the
next year yeah I get the sense that
Louise Casey was actually saying he
needs to be completely disbanded and
start all over again would you agree
with that
um she used the phrase effectively
disband
um
she absolutely understands that we can't
disband it overnight because Parliament
and and Downing Street and embassies
need protecting so we need to create as
much chilliness as possible change how
it works change how it supervisors
change how all the Firearms commands
work but
um disbanding something doesn't work if
you've got a job to do tomorrow yeah so
my co-confident to you I mean I
completely understand that all those all
those organs should be protected but are
we actually protecting them by exposing
them to people that that review that you
yourselves are conducting into their
behavior would indicate that they're not
the kind of people that we should have
in the job in the first place now I
think we shouldn't use it in the general
term that doesn't mean they're not all
the kind of people she's having a job
there's lots of course there's lots of
good people there that's why the big
approach on Professional Standards um
the tougher approach on vetting the
investigations we're doing the reviewing
old cases all of that work is happening
so that across the mess including in
these specialist areas we can get rid of
the people who shouldn't be here
thank you Jeff um just before I come to
Tim Lawton I just want to ask you um
you've told you've told the committee
that you'd be swapping out at least
eight of the top 14 officer posts in the
Met to create a leadership team that can
succeed for the future I think you've
already started to do that I just wanted
to check with you have you got similar
plans for the Mets senior civilian
leadership team there's been some
stories about some of the people who've
been in the Met for a long time in
civilian posts and staff posts who are
still were I just wondered are you
managing to change those people as well
or are you just carrying on with the
people who were there before so that
we've got several senior posts being
advertised at the moment so yeah there's
a lot there's a lot of change taking
place at senior levels
so um we have um
two board level posts open for advert at
the moment and several posts at the
level below that
and they're going outside so so we will
take the best person Sometimes the best
person might come from inside sometimes
when we're outside but a large
proportion will definitely come from
outside
and just remind me do you have any
independent scrutiny of when you're
appointing people do you have
independent people who are not part of
the met on your selection board
um so for the most senior post yes we
sometimes involve City Hall and we've
got um non-executive directors
independent people on our board who help
us with some of these processes as well
so for the most senior posts we always
have somebody different there and that's
as well yes yes okay thank you Tim
Lawton thank you chair um Samar can I be
less diplomatic than Mr Anderson when I
came in this morning there were 10
police officers shadowing 10 rather
shabby looking Eco terrorists with their
banners bringing the whole of the
traffic around Parliament Square to a
standstill when we asked you about this
subject in a previous hearing you
acknowledge that the terms of the
traffic act 1980 whatever it was
would apply to anybody who was
obstructing the highway and not allowing
people going about their legitimate
business those protesters were in breach
of that act why were they not stopped or
moved to another place on a very wide
pavement that's available around
Parliament where they could have held
their protest peacefully without
disrupting people trying to give out
their business
so that's not an accurate reflection of
what I said when I was here before
we we have to allow some Highway
obstruction before it becomes so
unreasonable to be able to intervene
because of people's rights to protest
that's the legal framework created I'm
not saying that's right or wrong in
terms of that's how it should be but
that's how it is
and so what offices are always balancing
is
allowing a reasonable amount of protests
but not allowing it to become seriously
seriously disruptive
there is no definition in law of serious
disruption Parliament is currently
working on that and I think there's been
a the bill has been doing ping pong
between the Lords and the comments on
that that Clarity that that definition
will bring will make it easy for us to
intervene they clearly obstructed the
highway that is under the existing law
of the highways act there was an
alternative for them to carry on their
protest statically or even marching
slowly up and down the pavement which
the police could have redirected them to
that would not have been unreasonable
unless they had permission to bring
Parliament Square to a standstill and as
we speak I gather they're doing a
similar exercise up and down uh
Whitehall they have broken the law you
have not arrested them or moved them on
that's incorrect as I've said it's not
simply about the breach of the
obstruction of the highway there is
plenty of case law that says that is
permitted for protest
and we are having to we're having to
work in a very uncertain legal framework
which is why I'm grateful that
um the Prime Minister and Home Secretary
have responded to our ask and there's an
act going through Parliament at the
moment trying to Define serious
disruption
because that's what we have to wrestle
with it's it's not as straightforward as
saying you can immediately arrest
somebody for obstructing the highway if
they're protesting I'm not even
suggesting you arrest them I'm
suggesting we'll move them on gen you
gently nudge them towards a very
convenient pavement space which would
not cause inconvenience to the public
and our constituents
I see we're not going to agree on how we
Define existing legislation if the new
legislation going through Parliament now
does become law in anything like its
current form would that protest this
morning not therefore have happened
I'd need to see it but I think it's up
so I haven't seen the detail that you
the video perhaps you've seen but I
think it's less like from your
description of it it's a lot less likely
it would it would be legal
what would you have done so there were
there are 10 demonstrators with their
banners across several highways of
parliament Square walking very very
slowly so no traffic could pass except
for bicycles so that is disrupting the
traffic and people going about their
their business it's very clear you know
what the new legislation is going to uh
to say surely under the new legislation
the minute they got their banners out
and stood in the middle of the road you
would have moved them on or arrested
them if they refused to be moved on yes
under the new legislation which I think
talks about
um serious disruption being anything
that causes more than a minor
inconvenience to others then that would
seem to be in breach and therefore it
would lead to a police intervention okay
I think scene scenes do is yeah quite a
bit of worrying given that this is quite
controversial legislation to deal with
precisely this sort of thing however
let's get back to the case in hand it
brings me to the subject of public
confidence
and if the public can't have confidence
that you know how to use new laws which
are very clearly intended to stop
demonstrations causing Havoc to ordinary
a law-abiding taxpayers this morning
then it's not surprising whilst the
public is rapidly losing confidence in
police generally and in the Met
particularly now yesterday we had the
minister here with officials from the
home office on this subject we were
talking about the met and apparently you
are now required to write a weekly
letter to the Home Secretary on the
progress you're making to resolve I'm
not required we do that routinely it's
not a requirement you have offered to to
do that and that so the dear swella
letter which is weekly winging its way
to the home office is there any problem
with that letter being made public it's
very operationally sensitive it's got a
lot of current cases in it so yes there
is a problem with that
do you think you should do a version
which could be made public so it gives
some confidence to the public that
you're taking your mission seriously in
our making progress or not
I think there's lots of ways we do
Public Communication I think doing a
weekly letter to London is probably not
a way I would choose to do it but we
will do regular public updates on big
issues we have lots of releases going
out with the media
um where the big themes like the update
on misconduct and standards that letter
was publicized on the third or fourth of
April so we will routinely put material
out there to show the progress we're
making but I'm not sure a weaker letter
is the way I would do it the mayor
apparently is going to be holding
regular interviews with uh with you with
um greater London members to again
scrutinize this progress we're not sure
what form they're going to take because
they've not started yet would you be
amenable to those taking place in public
it's a choice for Lemire but I'm relaxed
about that so you'll be very happy to be
held accountable by the mayor and London
counselors in a public forum
um by the mayor so the law says I'm
accountable to the mayor because he's
the police and crime commissioner for
London
right but in the term of these proposed
venues which will be appearing at
regularly you are perfectly comfortable
if they're in the public forum
if that's what the mayor seeks that's
fine
I'm good that will go in our report
hopefully as a recommendation to the to
the mayor when we last visited Scotland
Yard we had a meeting with the
Professional Standards managers and
they're obviously an important part of
delving through officers who have
perhaps not been as closely scrutinized
in the past as they should have been
about remaining as serving officers
which is
um uh is is highly desirable
um unfortunately we run out of time at
that meeting because the room was booked
for some other important body within
Scotland Yard so we were turfed out so
we didn't quite have the time to finish
our questioning one of the areas where I
certainly suggest there might be
improvements is that at the moment
you're moving more serving police
officers into the Professional Standards
boards to oversight see the work of the
potential uh misdemeanors of other
police officers I.E police marking their
own homework do you not think there is
now an overriding ways that the
Professional Standards Board should
consist of a number of very experienced
people from bodies outside of the police
to scrutinize the conduct of the police
and the records that they're going
through at the moment
so we're bringing outside experts to
um to oversee the work and to to look at
our work and I think that's really
important of course we already have the
most serious cases to dealt with by the
independent office of police complaints
if we are going to reform the
organization though leaders need to have
the ability to deal with the standards
issues and the more you take it out the
organization the harder you make it to
be one of the consequences of Legally
qualified chairs taking over misconduct
panels from senior police officers over
the last six or seven years is how is
those independent lawyers sack fewer
people they so the further people are
away from it the more forgiving they are
of the behavior is what I've seen so I
want I want the powers to be able to
deal with this yeah I'm not talking
about misconduct
um panels and there are serious problems
with the iopc as you know as this
committee has reported on not least its
chief executive and Joint chairman is
currently under investigation and has
left the post so there's only an acting
chief executive there at the moment what
we suggested is that within those people
who are overseeing investigations who
are directing how thorough those
investigation should be the sort of
thresholds that investigations should
meet before further action could then be
required against police officers should
contain an element of outside
professionals from the Army for example
who seem to be much better at rooting
out
people who are not appropriate for the
uh for the Army to be part of that
department to advise what's wrong with
that
so I say we've got so many advisors
already helping us with some of our work
so I think having advisors is external
advisors is really helpful and we're
doing more and more of that they are
Consultants they are not sitting
alongside serving police officers giving
views making judgments on how to take
cases further or not it seems to me a
box ticking exercise and if you
seriously want to restore exercise at
all well
that's what we were told when we went to
see Scotland Yard because they're not
they're not talking exercise they are
not at the top table
they all they are having full access and
looking at the decision making and
Advising on whether we're going decision
making right on some of the most tricky
cases so it is not box sticking it is
really substantial work on a few
individual high profile cases you may
have had some outside advice you're
looking at over a thousand officers or
even uh even even more the thresholds on
which they're um judge the criteria that
now needs to be applied to them is being
designed almost exclusively by serving
police officers whereas the view of this
committee and of our discussions and I
thought also the impression of some of
the people who are in that department
who sort of said well that's a good idea
isn't it was that you would benefit from
having a completely different
perspective and a fresh set of eyes from
people from other
agencies who have no flag or whatever
for the uh for the for the police can
apply some of their own disciplines
which have worked quite well in other
organizations with single little failed
in the met so far I just don't see what
the problem is we're bringing them in at
the top table properly which they're not
at the moment
so we're I'm not sure I'm fully
understand the point so we're bringing
external advisors in
we're always open to recruiting people
from outside the organization it may be
something we'll adopt in the future it's
just not so I'm going to commit to now
at the moment with a
a different legal framework to people in
other walks of life the fact you've got
these police regulations having people
who are expert in that is quite
important and
I think using the team we've got at the
moment enhanced as it is hopefully with
new regulations can make the bulk of the
difference as long as we have some of
that external eye over some of our most
critical decisions to make sure that
we're not tipping it in the wrong
direction see we understand they're
going to be new checks and balances
about ongoing professional scrutiny in
the future which is a which is a good
thing
but of course that doesn't apply to all
those whose misdemeanors are historic
um who are being looked at at the moment
by the police themselves so are you
convinced that there is sufficient rigor
in ongoing professional practice
scrutiny for those people who've been
with the police historically as well as
those new people coming in who will be
subject to higher thresholds or
suitability hopefully
so we're six months into my
commissionership there is a lot more
rigor than there was six months ago I'm
sure we'll be increasing it further
okay we are going to have to conclude at
this point before you go
um I just wanted to ask if you would
write to the committee about two issues
one is we've been told that the mayor
has the worst records for the quality of
files passed to the CPS I think 38 to 40
of files submitted uh only sorry only 38
to 40 Reach the the standard that's
expected by the CPS so do you think you
could write to me about what you're
doing in terms of sorting out the the
files going to the CPS the other issue
was we were told by the chair of the
independent scrutiny and oversight board
that she believes there needs to be more
communication and join up between
London's local race action plan and the
national police race action plan so
could you write to us about how you're
engaging with the national race action
plan to ensure that the Met is going to
deliver the national plan and it
complements the work of the local London
plan as well would that be possible to
do that sure I mean on the second one we
are adopting the national race action
plan that is our approach it hasn't been
historically we changed that on my watch
so
run home on her own plan that reflects
it gently we're adopting it fully okay
I'm raising the concerns of the chair
quite recently so is that a decision
you've made in in recent times um in the
last two or three months yes the last
two or three months oh okay all right
okay well thank you for telling me that
because that's not what the what the
chair of the independent oversight board
told us but anyway okay can I thank you
very much for your time and you've had
some very robust questioning uh but we
feel very we feel this is such an
important issue and we're hoping that
you'll be able to come back before the
committee in the months and years to
come to show how the Met is changing I'd
be very keen to do that and can I finish
make one final comment
of course it's important that when a big
organization is failing in many respects
that you're robust in your challenge of
us
but can I ask you to think about
the tens of thousands of men and women
who come to come to work to protect
London and give up their best day in and
day out and I don't mind how tough you
are with me and how robust the language
is about the people who shouldn't be in
the organization
that they desperately need your support
if they're if we're going to succeed and
if we can if we can ensure that's part
of the conversation that would be really
helpful well I think that's reflected in
the fact that committee has spent the
last few months
on the inquiry into policing priorities
to make sure that the police are
actually providing the level of service
and focusing on the things that the
public wants so please rest assured this
committee is very focused on getting the
very best out of our police forces and
supporting the many many excellent
police officers that we have serving in
police forces all around the country
thank you very much thank you for your
time today thank you very much we're
going to suspend shortly
couldn't pass